[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn herzlich Willkommen an
diesem sonntagmittags schön dass Sie
dabei sind es fällt in diesen Zeiten ja
nicht leicht zumindest eine Spur
Optimismus zu bewahren die Lage in
Europa wird immer bedrückender Putins
Krieg eskaliert die Inflation hat
sagenhafte zehn Prozent erreicht und die
führenden Wirtschaftsforscher warnten
diese Woche in aller Deutlichkeit wenn
es uns nicht gelingt mit der vorhandenen
Energie über den Winter zu kommen dann
droht nicht nur eine Rezession sondern
eine wirklich tiefe Krise umso
betrüblicher dass wir in diesen Zeiten
eine Regierung haben die wochenlang
schwankt und streitet was zu tun ist um
zu verhindern dass firmenmassenhaft
pleitegehen Angesicht zu agaspreise
Verbraucher millionenfach ihre
Rechnungen nicht bezahlen können diese
Woche schaffte die Ampel einen
Befreiungsschlag sie hat zumindest einen
Weg zur lö gefunden mit 200 Milliarden
Euro 9 Schulden sollte etwas wie eine
gaspreisbremse oder ein Deckel
konstruiert werden Details sind noch
unklar eine Kommission soll sie
herausfinden aber die ampelregierung
lobt sich schon mal mit großen Worten
für ihre große Tat unser Thema heute mit
Doppel Wums gegen die Gaspreise
Befreiungsschlag oder schuldengrab und
ich freue mich auf diese Gäste Anna
Lehmann ist bei uns sie leitet das
parlamentsbüro der Tageszeitung taz
herzlich willkommen ich freue mich auf
Daniel Wetzel aus der
Wirtschaftsredaktion der Welt ich
begrüße Wolfgang m Schmidt Dreier
Journalist und verantwortlich für den
Podcast Wohlstand für alle und Antje
Hoening ist wieder bei uns Leiterin der
Wirtschaftsredaktion der Rheinischen
Post ich habe es gesagt große Worte zu
großen Taten in der Pressekonferenz war
Olaf Scholz mit diesem Wort ganz von ich
habe aber andere Gelegenheit gesagt die
Maßnahmen die wir ergreifen sind Bums
man kann sagen dass es hier ein
doppelbums es soll dazu beitragen dass
jetzt schnell zügig und für alle schnell
feststellbar die Preise sinken für
Energie so dass sich niemand Sorgen
machen muss wenn er an den Herbst und
den Winter denkt wenn er an Weihnachten
denkt und dann das nächste Jahr und dann
die Rechnung auch die hohen Rechnungen
die einige jetzt bereits bekommen haben
als Abschlagszahlung werden sich dann
wieder reduzieren können das ist das
konkrete ziel der Maßnahme und der
Förderung die wir uns vorgenommen haben
doppelwurms heißt das Wort danke dass
Sie in den sozialen Netzwerken wieder
dabei sind bei tagesschau.de
presseclub.de danke für Ihre Kommentare
die ich hier lese Frau Höning eine Frage
die immer wieder gestellt wird bevor wir
mal in die komplizierten Details gehen
ist die nach dem wann Olaf stolz spricht
davon im Herbst im Weihnachten soll
Entlastung da sein die Frage ist wann
spüren die VerbraucherInnen Verbraucher
die Unternehmen was von der Bremse
das wird ja davon abhängen wie das
ausgeschaltet wird da sind ja noch sehr
viele Details offen
jetzt haben sie ja erstmal zum ersten
Oktober gespürt dass die Mehrwertsteuer
auf Gas gesenkt wurde das wurde ja zum
Glück nicht zurückgenommen ob die
Verbraucher davon etwas überhaupt spüren
wird sich ja noch zeigen wenn die Preise
steigen ja auch parallel weiter also das
wird so oder so ein harter Winter ich
glaube nicht dass jemand das als
Entlastung finden wird ganz viele Fragen
sind ja noch offen macht man es so dass
man sagt jeder muss kriegt die Hälfte
des Strom des Gasverbrauchs quasi zum
günstigen Preis und den Rest zum teuren
oder gibt es dieses komplizierte Modell
das ist erst ein basisverbrauch von 5000
Kilowattstunden etwa pro Haushalt gibt
das wird alles sich noch zeigen wenn wir
uns gleich drüber ich versuche mal mehr
rauszulocken was die Frage nach dem wann
angeht Herr Werte Olaf Scholz sagt
Entlastung im Herbst und zu Weihnachten
ja die gaskommission tagt ja noch und
wird erst Ende Oktober wahrscheinlich
Ergebnisse bringen dann müssen die noch
umgesetzt werden also wenn man im
November Dezember eine Regelung hat dann
ist das schon mal gut und viele
Energieversorger haben ja traditionell
zum ersten Januar ihre Preise mal
angepasst zumindest im Strombereich man
würde jetzt erwarten dass man zum ersten
Januar was sieht okay das wäre zumindest
eine Perspektive Herr Schmidt andere
Länder einfach an Frankreich hat mit
ähnlichen Instrumenten erreicht dass die
Inflation schon wieder spürbar singt
sind wir zu spät oder gerade rechtzeitig
wir sind vielleicht noch gerade
rechtzeitig wenn man sich jetzt beeilt
denn tatsächlich ist das auch eine
inflationsbremse und so sollte man es
auch vor allem verkaufen es wird nicht
die große Entlastung geben noch knallen
keine sektgurken und das wird auch nicht
eintreten aber ich glaube es ist jetzt
der richtige Schritt ob man das
unbedingt doppelbums nennen muss ich
weiß es nicht also Bazooka was Phase ist
Drums doppelbums also ich habe da
stilistische Probleme mit ich würde
vorschlagen morgens Feiertag wir lesen
mal zehn Seiten Thomas Mann und haben
dann wieder Sprachgefühl es war Leben an
kommt schon der Sache näher dass
vielleicht zum ersten Januar sagt der
Wechsel was zu erwarten ist Herr Schmidt
sagt das ist gerade noch rechtzeitig
haben Sie eine Vorstellung wie stark das
entlastend wirken kann für Betriebe und
Haushalte also wie heftig dieser
doppelbums wirklich empfunden wird
Doppelpunkt finde ich eigentlich auch
ein falsches Sprachbild weil so viel
Geld ist es ja dann doch nicht wenn man
sich überlegt dass im Zuge der
corona-krise so viel Geld ist es nicht
wenn man sich überlegt dass im Zuge der
corona-krise oder für die Bankenrettung
jeweils fünf und 500 und 600 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung gestellt werden dann
ist 200 Milliarden doch eine
überschaubare Summe und wann es spürbar
wird hängt natürlich wie sie sagen von
der Ausgestaltung ab einige Entlastungen
kommen ja jetzt schon für die
VerbraucherInnen die
energiepreispauschale ist wirksam das
Kindergeld wird erhöht gut 18 Euro
Mehrwertsteuer wird gesenkt dass man
wird es wahrscheinlich nicht dadurch
spüren dass man denkt oh jetzt hat man
mehr Geld im Portemonnaie sondern man
hat nicht so viel weniger im
Portemonnaie also es ist
Abmilderung der zu erwartenden Belastung
was glaube ich essentiell sein wird ist
die Wirtschaft also wird es gelingen
diese drohende Rezession abzuwenden wird
das Vertrauen der Betriebe wieder
steigen werden Produktion die jetzt zum
Teil schon zurückgehalten wird wird das
wieder angekuppelt verhindern wir
massenbetriebsschließungen
massenentlastung und davon wird es
glaube ich abhängen ob das wirkt oder
nicht das ist vor allen Dingen jetzt
erstmal ein psychologischer Effekt das
ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt auf den ich
gleich gerne zurückkommen will was die
Wirtschaft angeht
versuchen wir mal zu skizzieren Herr
Wetzel was ist denn eigentlich genau der
Plan also Schulden aufnehmen ist einfach
das haben wir verstanden aber in welcher
Weise kommt das Geld dann wer kriegt wie
viel was glaube ich sehr wichtig zu
sagen dass die Bundesregierung nicht in
die großhandelsmärkte eingreift die
funktionieren weiter wie bisher also mit
diesem Geld mit diesen 200 Milliarden
wird jetzt nicht der Preis gedrückt
sozusagen das wird nicht passieren
jedenfalls nicht durch das was die
Bundesregierung beschlossen hat damit
mit dem Geld werden Verbraucher
subventioniert da werden
Industrieunternehmen bezuschusst und
Haushalte sollen ja wohl ein Energie
Sockel bekommen eine ein Grundbedarf
soll in subventioniert zur Verfügung
gestellt werden vom von ihrem jeweiligen
Versorger und der Versorger macht dann
die Differenzkosten beim Start geltend
so dann kommen nicht viele Rechnungen
sozusagen zwei Teile ich bekomme etwas
Gas günstiger dafür zahlt der Staat an
meine Stadtwerke oder meinen Versorger
und einen anderen Teil muss ich voll
bezahlen so ist das so ist das geplant
allerdings muss man sagen dass diese
diese man nennt es falschlicherweise
gaspreisdeckel dass diese
subventionierte Teil der Gasrechnung der
wird nicht bei bei dem früheren
Gaspreisniveau bleiben also wird sich
immer noch sicherlich mindestens
verdoppeln oder verdreifachen und dann
kommt noch wenn man nicht spart
tatsächlich noch mal der Marktpreis der
beim zehnfachen heute liegt noch mal
oben drauf ja also das sparanreiz bleibt
in jedem Fall erhalten und niemand
sollte sich Illusionen machen dass er zu
den höheren Preisen weiterhin Gas
bekommt und verbrauchen kann also es
wird bei einer Verdopplung beim
Verbraucher mindestens bleiben bei
Höning dann Herr Schmidt den Satz der
spar-anreiz bleibt erhalten finde ich
ein bisschen gefährlich der Bund will
zwar nicht alles subventionieren aber
doch ein Teil und die große Sorge ist
dass der Spar Anreiz eben nicht
ausreichend erhalten bleibt wir haben
gehört dass der Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur am Freitag
eindringlich gewarnt hat selbst bei den
heutigen nicht subventionierten Preisen
hohen Preisen sparen die Leute nicht
genug damit kommen wir nicht über den
Winter nur wenn die Haushalte auch ihren
Sparbeitrag leisten vermeiden wir eine
gasmangelage und uns nützt keine schöne
Preisbremse etwas wenn wir kein Gas mehr
haben dann ist die Frage der Kosten das
zweitrangige Problem und diese Gefahr
sehe ich wirklich und darum ist das ein
ganz schwieriger doppelwumms auch wenn
er von den Zahlen her Wumms hat aber
Freundin es stehen ja viele Menschen
einfach mit dem Rücken an der Wand
Helmut schlebeiß vom Sparkassenverband
hat gesagt es trifft auch die Haushalte
die 3600 Euro netto zur Verfügung haben
da sind wir in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft angekommen und die haben
keine Möglichkeit mehr irgendwas zu
sparen die müssen an ihr Erspartes wenn
Sie welches haben und deswegen muss da
entlastet werden da kann man nicht sagen
ja friert halt dann wird auch gespart
ich sehe das Problem aber ich glaube
auch wie Herr Wetzel sagt es wird
keineswegs so sein dass da jetzt Leute
auf die Idee kommen zu heizen und die
Fenster aufzureißen ich habe mich ich
habe mich ehrlich gesagt gewundert über
die Bemerkung des Vorsitzenden
Bundesnetzagentur der gesagt hat die
Verbraucher die verbrauchen ja mehr Gas
als im letzten Jahr ja aber der Herbst
ist ja auch viel kälter man sagt ja
normalerweise beginnt die Heizsaison am
1 Oktober wir hatten Mitte September ein
kältereinbruch da wurde die Heizung
aufgedreht und das zeigen übrigens auch
die Wetterdaten dass dieser September
kälter ist als der im vergangenen Jahr
und so kann man eigentlich nicht passt
prototo vergleichen diesen September mit
dem nächsten september und viele
Menschen sparen bereits jetzt das zeigt
ja auch den Kopf zurückhaltend
das sprang zeigt sich natürlich dann
wenn es kalt ist also wenn es warm ist
es ist ein leichtes kein Gas zu
verwenden für ihn wollte ich doch mal
eben sagen Sie haben ja vollkommen recht
viele Betriebe viele Menschen stehen mit
dem Rücken zur Wand Rentner
Geringverdiener Hartz IV Empfänger
sowieso das ist ja auch keine Frage dass
der Staat helfen muss und zwar Bürger
und Betrieben nur der Weg ist der
falsche er soll es nicht über Preis
Bremsen machen er soll nicht am Markt
Mechanismus herumfummeln das ist noch
nie gut gegangen in der Geschichte
sondern viel sinnvoller wäre es wenn der
Staat gezielt hilft genau das ist ja
auch das was die Ökonomen und
Wirtschaftsweisen fordern weg von der
Manipulation an den Preisen um den
Anreiz zu zerstören hin zu direkten
Hilfen für die Bedürftigen sowohl Bürger
als auch Firmen aber ist das nicht das
Bild eines Marktes wo sich das wirklich
noch richtig klären kann und wir haben
doch beim Energiemarkt ist nicht mit so
einem schönen preisfindungsprozess zu
tun sondern wir haben es da mit
geopolitischen Verwerfungen mit all dem
zu tun also da muss ja der Staat
eingreifen wir haben es ja auch mit
staatlichen Akteuren zu tun wenn wir
sehen wer verdient eigentlich an Öl an
Gas und so weiter das heißt hier glaube
ich müssen wir doch erkennen dass ein
aktiver Start sehr wohl da richtige
Akzente setzen können
am Preis spielen Frau Höning hat glaube
ich nur gesagt und richtigerweise gesagt
dass es stark auf politische
Kommunikation jetzt ankommt wir haben
uns ja lange Zeit an der gasumlage
festgebissen kommunikativ und da haben
gesagt wenn die weg ist das alles gut
und ja viele Leute glauben jetzt ist die
gasumlage Weg jetzt ist alles prima
jetzt können wir weiter verbrauchen das
ist das was in vielen Köpfen hängen
bleiben geblieben ist und das war
natürlich eine absoluter
Nebenkriegsschauplatz da haben sich
viele Leute drauf geworfen weil sie
gesehen haben da kann man immer die
Grünen Minister kritisieren da hat er
mal ein Fehler gemacht so dass es nur
ein ganz kleiner Teil gewesen das waren
2,4 Cent ne und jetzt glauben die Leute
gar zum Lager ist weg alles prima und
das ist ein Fehler da muss man sehr
aufpassen dass man jetzt nicht die
Kommunikation so macht der Staat gibt
das Geld er schafft die gasumlage ab so
wir sind gerettet
den Kommentar von mir alvera bei Twitter
mit werden denn auch Maßnahmen zum
Einsparen entwickelt durch eine
Preisbremse wird doch nicht magisch Gas
erzeugt
naja wie gesagt das man muss
kommunizieren das einfach
große Kosten hängen bleiben nicht also
wir reden nicht über eine
Nettoentlastung sondern über eine
Belastungsgrenze wie sie richtig gesagt
haben also
die Leute müssen einfach wissen selbst
wenn ich 80 Prozent meines früheren
verbrauchsubventioniert bekomme die
anderen 20 Prozent die ich dann bezahlen
muss die muss ich mit den zehnfachen des
früheren Wertes bezahlen dann kommen
netto eine drei verdreifache Rechnungen
hinten raus also dass Dilemma glaube ich
ist beschrieben also das eine ist die
notwendige Entlastung damit man nicht
pleite geht oder Insolvenz anmelden muss
und das andere ist der objektive Mangel
an Energie vor allem an Gas und da
ändert ja die Preisgestaltung also ist
aber wenn es insgesamt billiger wird ist
das noch kein Anreiz weniger zu
verbrauchen vor allem wie groß sehen Sie
denn die Gefahr die die Wirtschaft
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitute diese
Woche beschrieben haben sie haben gesagt
wenn es zu einer gasmangellage kommt
also therapeutisch wenn kein Gas mehr da
ist im Winter dann kann die
Volkswirtschaft mit 8% einbrechen also
ein Ausmaß dass wir noch nicht erlebt
haben wie groß ist die Gefahr dass wir
einen Absturz der Volkswirtschaft haben
ich denke die ist da und die ist groß
das hat sich schon im Sommer gezeigt
insofern hat mich gewundert dass die
Regierung so lange gezögert hat bis sie
dieses Paket vorgestellt hat ich kann
nur berichten von dem Besuch bei BASF im
August die haben gesagt sie haben also
die haben Gas also in Schwarzheide im
Standort Schwarzheide die haben
Gaskraftwerk auf ihrem
Gelände die arbeiten auch mit Gas als
Rohstoff die haben gesagt unsere
Produktionsanlagen sind nur zu 60
Prozent ausgelastet und zwar weil wir
nicht konkurrenzfähig sind
und die haben damals schon gesagt wir
brauchen Unterstützung ich füge einfach
nach ein herrscht mit wir erleben das ja
schon an verschiedenen Stellen AdBlue so
einen treibstoffzusatz wird nicht mehr
hergestellt weil die Produktion zu teuer
ist jemand der in der gaskommission
mitarbeitet hat mir gesagt
salzsäureproduktion sei gerade ein
großes Problem und können an vielen
Stellen lahmlegen was wir dringend für
den Alltag brauchen also wir schätzen
sie das ein das ist sehr ernst denn wir
müssen sehen das ist etwas anderes als
bei der corona-krise wo wir Restaurants
oder so geschlossen haben das ist für
die Binnenwirtschaft problematisch aber
da kann man sehr unterstützend
eingreifen wir sind natürlich auch in
einem globalen Wettbewerb und wenn da
die deutsche Industrie zusammenbricht
oder zumindest nicht so produzieren kann
wie gewohnt dann verliert man natürlich
an Wettbewerbsvorteilen und da ist die
Angst groß und diese Angst ist auch
berechtigt und es ist erstaunlich dass
es ja Ökonomen gab wo ein bisschen der
Wunsch Vater des Gedanken war es im März
die schon glaubten wir können eigentlich
sofort aus dem gasausstein es wird ganz
leicht gehen vielleicht zwei drei
Prozent BP weniger nee wir sehen gerade
wie krass das sein kann obwohl wir noch
weiter ja bislang noch Gas bezogen
hatten auch aus Russland also es ist
eine sehr heikle Situation und
vielleicht hat man dann doch was das
angeht zu lange gezögert auch was die
Bremse anbelangt die Ökonomen Isabella
im Weber hat das im Februar vorgestellt
das Konzept und jetzt ist sie auch in
diesem Gremium es ist also sehr gut
besetzt sie kennt sich aus mit Preis
bremsen und Kontrollen aber es hat lange
gedauert man hat dicke Bretter gebohrt
Frau Höning Herr wernsel was tun die
Industrie spart ja in der Tat schon sehr
viel Gas an der hat ja die Netzagentur
nichts auszusetzen und das liegt daran
dass die auf diese Preissignal reagieren
weil es so teuer ist sparen Sie gerade
ein und zu den acht Prozent das ist
natürlich wirklich etwas was wir noch
nicht hatten das hat mir nicht in der
Finanzkrise es hat mir nicht in der
corona-krise sondern Rezession hatten
wir noch nicht das ist eine Dimension an
die wir uns da gewöhnen müssen die uns
da droht umso wichtiger eben den um das
nochmal zu markieren also es besteht
Einvernehmen am Tisch also das ist
zunächst mal eine seriöse Prognose das
falls wir kein Gas mehr haben dieser
Absturz so stattfindet also niemand
schüttelt den Kopf alle sagen ja das
heißt also die zentrale Frage ist doch
wie man genau das verhindern kann ja
genau das muss man indem man diese
Sparvorgaben macht das muss man auch
machen indem man natürlich ab sofort
keine Gaskraftwerke mehr verwendet für
die Stromerzeugung in ganzen
Spitzenzeiten geht das ja nicht weil
Gaskraftwerke so schnell hochzuschalten
sind aber da ist sicher noch Spielraum
drin und vor dem Hintergrund ist es ja
auch richtig dass man da jetzt die
Laufzeiten für die Atomkraftwerke
verlängert um über diesen Winter zu
kommen man muss das Stromangebot auch da
erhöhen und den Garten das Gas das edle
Gas nicht mehr für die Stromproduktion
ja also was die Bundesregierung gemacht
aber richtig erstmal 200 Milliarden
locker machen um Industrie noch zu
subventionieren das wird so sein müssen
das Geld wird nicht reichen auch wenn
der Schmidt zu Recht an Thomas Mann
gemahnt hätte ich ja fast das Wort
Triple Bums noch eingeführt weil der
wird nötig werden glaube ich weil dieses
200 Milliarden ja über zwei Heizperioden
reichen sollen das wird nicht rein für
die Industrie brauchen wir unheimliche
Mengen an Geld um die am Leben zu
erhalten
dazu Algerien über Angebote und
Nachfrage muss man wirklich das Angebot
an Energie erhöhen sowohl auf der
stromseite als auch auf der Gasseite da
müssen wir reden über nicht nur über
Atomkraft und ein Kohlekraft wie das
jetzt bisher tun wir müssen auch reden
über Fracking wir müssen reden über neue
Erdgasquellen über Biogas und über alles
was man kriegen kann weil die Situation
ist so ernst zum Reden haben wir nicht
so viel Zeit also exakt ja mich wundert
ehrlich gesagt die Reihenfolge wir sagen
wir müssen zuerst über Atomkraftwerke
reden dann über Kohle dann über Fracking
und zum Schluss vielleicht auch noch
über erneuerbare ich meine im Strom-Mix
haben die Erneuerbaren mittlerweile
einen Anteil von über 50 Prozent und und
wenn man und wenn man sagt und und es
ist ja verwunderlich dass diejenigen die
jetzt am dringendsten fordern wir müssen
die Kernkraft verlängern am härtesten
gegen den Umstieg auf erneuerbaren
schnellsten geht wir haben ja drei AKWs
und sechs AKWs sind noch eine besondere
Erlaubnis haben schnell bei den
Erneuerbaren wenn man wenn man so wenn
man
erneuerbare muss man ausbauen aber es
wäre verfehlt glaube ich jetzt zu hoffen
dass sie schnellen Beitrag liefern
können wir haben ich muss sie mit Zahlen
ärgern wir haben Energieverbrauch in
Deutschland von 3.300 Terawattstunden so
wie viel hat denn Windkraft produziert
letztes Jahr 120 Terawattstunden das
sind 3,6 Prozent wir wollen den gesamten
Energie max steht die Karbonisieren und
alles auf Ökostrom umstellen und da hat
Windkraft stand heute 3,6 Prozent plus
Solar sind wir bei 5%, also jetzt so
hoffen wir bauen paar Windräder und dann
kommen wir aus der Krise das halte ich
für für diese dauert das zum Beispiel
sechs bis acht Jahre bis ein Windrad
also wenn man Sachen besteht ein Windrad
steht schon man man setzten größeres Rad
drauf es dauert es auch nicht noch eine
Betriebsleitung haben die haben mehr
Strom produziert CO2-frei als alle
deutschen Solaranlagen zusammen und die
könnte man ja aber
getan werden müsste also wir machen doch
wir bringen doch wieder neue ab
Möglichkeiten also wir werden doch wenn
wir jetzt auch noch den Fracking weg und
all das verfolgen wenn wir bald wieder
Glück auf der Steiger kommt singt und
alles dann kommen wir doch in eine Lage
wo wir jetzt noch 10 15 Jahre wieder so
weitermachen und dann wird man das so
für auch mal ein Windrad bauen es muss
doch jetzt wirklich dieser ganz große
Schritt passieren ich kann es ja
verstehen dass jetzt akut das ein oder
andere getan werden muss bei denen dann
auch die Grünen beide Augen zu drücken
müssen aber momentan sieht die
Energiewende so aus dass wir unser
Autokraten Portfolio ein bisschen
diversifiziert haben und Energie von
überall herholen wo wir früher nicht mal
Guten Tag sagten aber das kann doch
nicht dauerhaft so sein und wir sehen ja
auch schon welche Abhängigkeiten wir
geraten plötzlich müssen wir dann auch
nach Saudi-Arabien Waffen liefern und so
weiter um uns da lieb Kind zu machen das
kann doch nicht die Perspektive sein ein
paar Jahren da und haben den nächsten
Krisen her sind dran und dann ist Frau
Höning dran aber ich versuche es noch
mal zuzuspitzen damit wir
die Diskussion etwas verengen also also
es geht um die Frage wie wir über diesen
Winter kommen was die zweitschwierigste
Aufgabe zu sein scheint weil die
Gasspeicher im Moment gut gefüllt sind
und es geht dann verschärft um die Frage
wie wir über den Winter 23 24 kommen
weil wir ganz sicher durch die Ostsee
Pipelines die Speicher im nächsten
Sommer nicht mehr aufhören können also
es geht um Dinge die in ja sag mal uns
über die nächsten 16 18 Monate tragen
einige Experten sagen ja auch die Krise
dauert noch fünf Jahre okay ist richtig
ich sag ja nichts gegen die Energiewende
man muss sicherlich Windkraft wird ja
auch gemacht schneller ausbauen wenn man
weil jede Kilowattstunde hilft das
richtig so muss ich wäre mich dagegen
dass man sagt das könnte und jetzt in
den großen Schritt bringen das könnte
uns von diesem von diesen 3,6 Prozent
könnte uns das jetzt irgendwie in
ungeahnte Prozentzahlen katapultieren
das ist über Jahre nicht denkbar also
wenn man 80% Ökostrom bis 2030 schaffen
dann können wir drei Kreuze machen aber
in der jetzigen Krise helfen Windräder
mal gerade gar nichts das kann ich nur
unterstreichen Stichwort Leitungsausbau
Stichwort Naturschutz gegen
Ökostromausbau die Widerstände sind groß
Bayern hat das Problem ja teilweise auch
selbst verursacht kein Wunder dass die
jetzt ausgerechnet die AKWs brauchen zum
Thema Glück auf der Steiger kommt das
sind ja niemand mehr in Deutschland die
Steinkohle Zechen sind zu und selbst die
größten Fans der Steinkohle wollen die
nicht wieder aufmachen kostet Milliarden
dauert zehn Jahre was allerdings das
Tracking angeht da ist in Deutschland
durchaus was zu machen da müssen wir uns
nicht in die Hand von Autokraten begeben
wir könnten ich sage einmal für das
Publikum das nicht so kundig ist es geht
darum Gas das in der Erde vor allem in
Niedersachsen liegt durch Druck aus
tiefen Gesteinsschichten so zusammen und
rauszupressen dass es oberirdisch als
Gas zu verwenden ist genau das
LNG das Flüssiggas was wir derzeit aus
den USA ja massenhaft bekommen ist auch
gefragtes Gas das ist keine Technologie
des Teufels und in der Tat es ist die
Zeit der großen Tab aufbrechung müssen
wir auch darüber sprechen ob wir das
Fracking hier in Deutschland nicht doch
wieder betreiben wollen um uns auf
heimische Energiequellen zu besinnen und
auch dass der Import aus Katar ist im
Moment trotzdem die bessere Lösung
gegenüber der Lage kein Gas zu haben
Schmitze sind dran aber ich gebe Ihnen
noch die Frage mit falls nach der
niedersachsenwahl am nächsten Sonntag
wir eine
fracking-diskussion darüber bekommen
würden ob man das in Niedersachsen
anfängt wann würde uns das helfen
das kann ich schwer sagen es mag sein
dass es ein wenig schneller geht dann
als mit den erneuerbaren Energien aber
wir produzieren ja das nächste Umwelt
Desaster und wir können doch nicht immer
jetzt nur in dieser Kurzatmigkeit auf
alles reagieren sondern dann müsste man
eher mal überlegen wo kann man denn
sinnvoll noch mal einsparen also wie
würde dann jetzt müssen wir schnell
agieren aber wie würde dann Sparkonzept
23 24 aussehen damit wir nicht jetzt die
Umwelt neu verschmutzen auf eine neue
Weise wir werden ja auch Unglaub sich in
der Welt wir haben ja schon eine
schwache un Rede von Olaf Scholz jetzt
gehört wo er den anderen Ländern
irgendwie zu ruft ja man muss viel
machen Klimawandel aber wir machen viel
zu wenig und wir werden noch vollkommen
unglaubwürdig wenn wir jetzt all diese
Tabus brechen und man freut sich darüber
über den Tabubruch man aber dann
zugleich der Welt signalisiert na gut um
unseren Wohlstand zu retten sind wir zu
allem bereit aber ihr müsst euch jetzt
mal zurücknehmen aber die Realität ist
ja gerade dass wir Fracking Gas aus den
USA portieren und importieren müssen ja
so wenn sie Tracking im eigenen Land
nicht wollen dann können Sie eigentlich
auch die Fracking Gasimporte aus den USA
nicht gutheißen dann reicht das jetzt
nicht den den paradeweg gibt es gibt
jetzt sicherlich nicht die den goldenen
Weg dass man sagen kann so muss man es
auf jeden Fall machen nur wenn man jetzt
langfristig plant und Tracking da würde
ja niemand sein das machen wir mal bis
2026 und dann hören wir damit wieder auf
sondern es ist dann ein langfristiges
Geschäftsmodell das bleibt uns dann
bestimmt zwei drei Jahrzehnte erhalten
und das wird dann wieder so ein mühsamer
Kampf die gegen Kohlekraftwerk und
selbst das irgendwann eingestellt ist ja
unser Publikum ist wenn ich das richtig
sehe noch nicht ganz zufrieden mit dem
was wir hier analysieren und anbieten
können warum Abstriche bei den
Klimazielen wie wäre es mit Abstrichen
beim klimaschädlichen Konsum man anders
schreibt wenn ich kein Gas verbrauche
und spare dann zahle ich doch mit für
die die auf Stufe 4 alles wegheizen ist
das gerecht dann fragt jemand nach dem
Masterplan Wasserstoff viele viele
Äußerungen die vor allem mir klar machen
ja es fehlt Orientierung es gibt haben
sie jetzt gesagt es gibt zwei
Möglichkeiten wenn wir die nächsten
anderthalb Jahre sprechen weniger
verbrauchen oder mehr Energie besorgen
woher auch immer beides oder beides
vielleicht können wir es so machen
finde es klasse dass sie da
unterschiedliche Meinungen haben und
sich auch gegenseitig widersprechen aber
vielleicht können wir eine Runde machen
wo jede und jeder einmal sagt aus ihrer
per Betriebe sparen mehr Energie
besorgen in knappensätzen was wäre ihr
Plan Frau Höning fangen sie an ja muss
beides sein sparen muss sein deshalb die
gaspreisbremse abschaffen mehr Energie
besorgen keine Tabus Cutter zulassen
kurzfristig das besorgen was geht und
langfristig die Projekte nicht zu nicht
verlassen und das Thema Gerechtigkeit
was der Leser auf der Hörer aufgeworfen
hat der Zuschauer ist natürlich total
richtig ungerecht ist die gaspreisbremse
weil die davon profitieren auch Menschen
die sich die Preise leisten können und
die sich leisten müssen wir sind im
Krieg
sparen auf der einen Seite zusätzliche
Energie kurzfristig beschaffen aber
langfristig gucken dass man aus diesen
fatalen Abhängigkeiten rauskommt deshalb
sind ja die LNG Terminals die jetzt
gebaut werden auch Wasserstoff ready das
heißt das wird nicht so sein dass wir
auf Ewigkeiten sagen wir sind auf das
Fracking Gas auf die aus den USA
angewiesen sondern wir setzen auf
Wasserstoff finde ich richtig zum Thema
gaspreisbremse da gibt es ja Anreiz es
ist ja ja nicht so dass den Leuten so
gerät wird ihr könnt jetzt 36 Grad sein
Grad heizen sondern es wird ja nur ein
Grundverbrauch oder weniger sogar als
der Grundverbrauch subventioniert
Umverteilung bleibt trotzdem richtig ich
sehe das ist ein unspezifisches
Instrument ist aber ich sehe den
Energiemarkt ist ja die gaspreisbremse
da als das falsche Instrument da werden
wir beim Thema Steuern
Erbschaftssteuer dessen enthalte mich
zunächst der Rätsel und Herr Schnitt ja
der Zuschauer hat natürlich Recht wenn
er sagt Konsum einschränken aber das
passiert also wir haben eine
Inflationsrate von zehn Prozent die
Leute werden ganze automatisch weniger
konsumieren allein schon wenn man wenn
Sie Ihre verdreifachte Abschlagsrechnung
Gas und Strom sehen dann wird man schon
sparen also das wird passieren das ist
ein Automatismus die Angebotsseite finde
ich immer noch nach wie vor
unterbelichtet also wir müssen wie
freiwilligen sagten mehr Energie
besorgen und zwar dringend weil das viel
an viel größeren Hebel hat als uns die
letzte Kilowattstunde abzusparen von
unserem Land zu sparen also sie haben
schon gesagt bestehende Atomkraftwerke
reaktivieren die noch betriebssicher
sind Fracking importer also alles was
man kriegen kann ist ihre Position Herr
Schmidt man kann nicht alles immer
progressiv gestalten und die
gaspreisbremse ist nicht progressiv
gestaltbar sie ist nun jetzt so dass
alle ein bisschen was davon haben und ja
die die man kann nicht alles so
gestalten dass die die reicher sind mehr
belastet werden und die die ärmer sind
dann weniger Belastung haben damit muss
man leben man kann aber woanders ja
progressiv etwas gestalten man kann ja
auch eine Erbschaftssteuer oder sonst
was einführen wenn man das unbedingt
möchte das muss aber nicht immer bei
jeder einzelnen jetzt energiepolitischen
Maßnahmen nicht diskutiert werden ich
glaube da verlieren wir uns im
kleinteiligen ja natürlich muss Energie
beschafft werden aber
langfristig und mit langfristig meine
ich schon in zwei drei vier Jahren und
nicht in 15 Jahren müssen wir uns
vollkommen anders aufstellen und ich
glaube der große Hemmschuh und wir
Großheim schon auch warum es so spät
jetzt eingeführt wurde mit der Bremse
ist dass Christian Lindner an der
Schuldenbremse festhalten will und wir
brauchen jetzt eigentlich die große
investitionsoffensive was erneuerbare
Energien anbelangt wird gern hier einen
Strich ziehen sie haben unterschiedliche
Meinungen und Konzepte angeboten das
spiegelt die Debatte wieder die wir
haben
ich habe jetzt eigentlich noch zwei
Themen die ich mit Ihnen besprechen
möchte einmal weil es unser Publikum
auch stark interessiert ist die nach der
Bezahlung dieser 200 Milliarden und dann
wenn wir es schaffen durch noch einen
Blick auf die Regierung werfen wollen
aber fangen wir mal mit den 200
Milliarden an die Bundesregierung bleibt
maximal Maximilian romantur so als gehe
es um Geschenke oder Unterstützung von
der Regierung tatsächlich zahlen das
doch die Bürger selbst vor allem die
späteren Generationen vorhin können wir
uns die 200 Milliarden leisten ist das
jetzt der richtige Weg
mein wir denken gegen die Preisfrage
habe ich ja gesagt an den 200 Milliarden
an sich wir werden ganz viel Geld
aufwenden müssen und dabei wird es auch
nicht bleiben und es ist tatsächlich so
dass es die folgenden Generationen
zahlen da wird ja ein bisschen getrickst
Herr Lindner hat gesagt er zieht das vor
die Klammer es ist nicht im
Bundeshaushalt deshalb verletzt er
formal nicht die Schuldenbremse faktisch
setzt da die natürlich aus und wenn wir
über Vertrauen und Kommunikation
sprechen wäre es ja schon sinnvoll wenn
die Regierung sich da auch ehrlich macht
und nicht da jetzt diesen Budenzauber
aufhört also dafür egal aber dafür
werden die unsere Kinder werden dafür
zahlen ja und jedes Geld was sehr
unnötigerweise ausgeben weil wir
Menschen damit unterstützen die es nicht
nötig haben erhöht die Last für die
folgenden Generationen finde ich
problematisch
ja es ist aber nicht alternativlos dass
die folgenden Generationen das Zahlen
ich finde es erstmal richtig das jetzt
Schulden aufgenommen werden das ist
schnell mobilisierbares Geld auf der
anderen Seite kann man ja auch mal auf
die Einnahme Seite schauen also
Deutschland ist ja warmes Land es gibt
12 Billionen Euro an Nettovermögen und
davon sind ein Drittel in der Hand von
einem Prozent also wenn man sagt man
will Leute die es wirklich nötig haben
nicht zusätzlich unter die es nicht
nötig haben nicht zusätzlich
unterstützen dann kann man mit
Instrumenten wie zum Beispiel einer
einmaligen Vermögensabgabe arbeiten laut
Berechnung des DEB würde das etwa 300
Milliarden Euro das ist das was jetzt in
dem
wirtschaftsstabilisierungsfonds steckt
und was im Sondervermögen im Bundeswehr
steckt bringen und dann hätte man es
schon mal gegenpannen sind laut
Berechnung der Wirtschaftsweise
ich glaube wir brauchen gar nicht immer
in dieser finanzierungsfalle zu kommen
sondern wir müssen auch einfach
anerkennen ein reiches Land das stabil
ist kann viel mehr Schulden machen als
Deutschland das ist gerade tut wir sind
noch unter 70 Prozent Schuldenquote USA
liegt bei 130%. Japan extrem Beispiel
250 Prozent und die haben noch nicht mal
eine nennenswerte Inflation das heißt es
wäre viel mehr Spielraum da und Lindner
hat ja noch mal gesagt wir bleiben bei
der Schuldenbremse das ist ein Signal an
die Kapitalmärkte aber wir haben jetzt
gesehen diese die Kapitalmärkte sind so
entspannt trotz dieses Schattenhaushalt
sein wir ruhig ehrlich von 200
Milliarden das sogar die Rendite auf
Staatsanleihen sogar runtergegangen ist
das heißt man ist da ganz entspannt und
wenn man jetzt nicht dauerhaft diese
konsumtiven Ausgaben hat also man kann
natürlich jetzt nicht das Gas zehn Jahre
der Bevölkerung finanzieren aber wenn
man investiert und da richtig viel Geld
in die Hand nimmt dann wird man eher als
Land attraktiver für die Kapitalmärkte
noch und dann hat man nicht den Eindruck
die machen nur Steuergeschenke oder so
etwas sondern hier hat ein Staat ein
Plan und das ist gerade der
Paradigmenwechsel den wir in den USA
beobachten können mit Joe Biden dass man
jetzt Industriepolitik völlig neu denkt
also es ist ja kein Vorbild wie die USA
Schuldenquoten zu produzieren
EU in der Eurozone ja diese Quoten und
es wird dieses Kosten und die Leute
werden es bezahlen genau da hat er
Zuschauer ja recht es ist kein Geschenk
es ist ein Geschenk was er selbst
bezahlen kann wie beim schlechten
Weihnachtsfest aber umso wichtiger dass
man keine Ausgaben tätig die nicht
notwendig sind
es ist ja richtig also ich glaube auch
wir können uns aus dieser Krise nur
hinaus investieren ja das heißt aber
auch dass wir die Investoren die nicht
verschrecken dürfen sozusagen also man
muss ja natürlich auch im Lande lassen
und wir müssen Investitionsbedingungen
gut halten so und dann wurde ja gestern
Gott sei Dank oder am Freitag noch von
der EU-Kommission beschlossen dass wir
übergewinne abschöpfen von Ölkonzern von
Stromkonzernen insbesondere kohlekonzern
atomkraftbetreibern und Windkraft und
solarbetreibern und da kommt schon der
klägliche Summe zusammen das heißt diese
200 Milliarden die sind zum Teil auch
dann gegenfinanzierbar allein durch
diese Abschaffung der übergewinne was ja
sehr problematisch
aber wir können es auch so schaffen und
ich finde dass die USA gerade einen sehr
gutes Beispiel sind das selbst ein
Politiker wie John Menschen dann erkennt
wir müssen das machen es gibt von der
Hollywood Diva Gabor die sind schön Satz
ein Mann mit einer dicken Geldbörse kann
gar nicht unattraktiv sein ich finde
diesen Satz sollte man jetzt Christian
Lindner mal sagen okay lassen wir einen
Moment sacken Herr Wetzel hat mit
anderen Worten gesagt man kann sich nur
raus investieren aus dieser Krise
aber was ich jetzt aus dieser Runde
mitnehme ist zum einen natürlich die
Frage also was heißt dann investieren im
Moment investieren wir in Konsum aber
sie haben gesagt es muss dann eben auch
Investitionen etwas sein was uns
nachhaltig stärker macht und die andere
Diskussion verlängern ich glaube fast
die werden wir bekommen wer bezahlt in
Teilen finanziert es sich selber gegen
aber wer sie haben gesagt wir sind im
Krieg also wer in der Gesellschaft die
Teile der Rechnung bezahlt die dann doch
wehtun das werden es gibt ja wir haben
eine Regierung aus drei Parteien das
leitet vielleicht sogar schon über zwei
von diesen drei Parteien sagen eine
Vermögensabgabe oder Steuer wäre
sinnvoll zwei sagen auch eine Reform der
Erbschaftssteuer wäre sinnvoll eine
Partei die zurzeit bei sechs Prozent ist
sagt das ist nicht sinnvoll ich glaube
man kann sich von 100% Parteien nicht
auf Dauer diktieren lassen was sinnvoll
ist und was nicht glauben Sie dass die
Ampel also wir wissen ja alle was was in
der Stadt passiert wenn die Ampeln
ausfallen und richtig funktionieren das
haben wir übertragenen Sinne jetzt in
den letzten Wochen gesehen wenn es
ständig hin und her springt zwischen
gelb-grün-rot glauben Sie dass Sie den
Weg findet im Herbst das was sie jetzt
angekündigt hat auch vernünftig
umzusetzen wir haben ja nur die
Behauptung dass es zu einer solchen
Preisbremse kommt ja das glaube ich ich
glaube auch dass Christian Lindner
verstanden hat dass er nicht nur die
Kapitalmärkte froh macht sondern ja auch
noch Wähler hat die jetzt sehr betroffen
sind durch diese hohen Preise weil sie
vielleicht Unternehmer sind und ich
glaube das auch Christian Lindner noch
mal in sich gehen muss und darüber
nachdenken muss wie man eigentlich eine
moderne Industriepolitik gestaltet und
da wird er mit der Schuldenbremse
irgendwann niemand mehr locken können
denn wir haben ja jetzt lauter Tricks
erfunden wie man sie ein bisschen aus
dem Weg geht wir sind aber jetzt ein
bisschen wie die Comic die über dem
Abgrund steht aber noch nicht runter
geguckt hat und mal erkennt
Schuldenbremse ist über zehn Jahre alt
und jetzt kann man sich von ihr trennen
wie es ihre Einschätzung gerne so ein
bisschen das Bild noch in Erinnerung
dieses selfie das citruselfi der grünen
und gelben Spitzen nach der Wahl vor den
Koalitionsverhandlungen und jetzt haben
wir das Gefühl gehabt in den letzten
Wochen die beiden behalten sich ständig
und oder Scholz ist vor allem Mediator
und vielleicht deshalb so wenig in
Erscheinung getreten ändert sich das
jetzt also ist das ein Befreiungsschlag
es ist zumindest politisch jetzt ein
Befreiungsschlag die mussten was tun
auch mit Wumms von den Zahlen her
sie sind zum Erfolg verdammt das letzte
was wir natürlich jetzt gebrauchen
könnten wäre eine Regierungskrise und
die FDP die ja vor fünf Jahren schon mal
Jamaika hat platzen lassen wird das auch
immer mit im Kopf haben dass sie sich
das nicht leisten kann der Sprengstoff
für diese Koalition zu sein deshalb
glaube ich wird es weitergehen zumal die
Opposition ja auch nicht besser
aufgestellt ist einer sagte es vorhin
schon kurz nach Kriegsausbruch hat
Friedrich Merz vorgeschlagen durch Nord
Stream eins sofort das Gas abzustellen
hätten wir das gemacht werden wir jetzt
schon in der Lage also wenn wir damals
schon in der Lage in der wir jetzt sind
also ich glaube es wird noch viel Streit
geben und gerade die im Harbeck und
Lindner werden sich da noch viel
befähigen Harbeck muss sehr die
gasumlage durchsetzen weil Lindner kein
Geld rausgerückt hat und jetzt kriegt er
die Prügel dafür dass er sie
einkassieren musste weil Lindner dann
doch Geld rausgerückt hat das ist ja
auch eine bizarre Lage aber die ich
glaube die Koalition zum Erfolg verdammt
und die wird halten und diesen Winter
überstehen
was wir sehen mit dieser Energiekrise
mit dem Stopp aller russischen Lieferung
ist ja so ein exogener Schock man sagt
ja auch schwarzer Schwan Event also
etwas was von normalerweise nie
auftreten würde womit niemand gerechnet
hat und ich glaube auch die FDP und der
Lindner wissen das dass es ein Event ist
dass man nicht mit gängigen
marktwirtschaftlichen Methoden einfach
mal so laufen lassen kann Angebote
Nachfrage wirken lassen soweit das würde
auch in der Lindner nicht denken und man
sieht ja schon was er was ermöglich
macht man sollte nur bedenken die die
Schuldenbremse hat er sich nie
ausgedacht die steht in der Verfassung
nicht da kann man nur auch nicht einfach
so so locker rangehen möglicherweise ist
das nicht schlecht was die jetzt gemacht
haben schattende Haushalte als Notlösung
klar ist also wir müssen in der
Situation wo es keine guten Lösungen
gibt das muss man sich einfach erstmal
verinnerlichen das alles hat Nachteile
alles hat Probleme es gibt keine guten
Lösungen da kann man sich nur zwischen
den schlechten Lösungen entscheiden und
da denke Schattenhaushalt ist besser als
verfassungsfall
gezeichnet haben ich frage mal nachher
wechseln dann Herr Schmidt das Bild dass
sie gezeichnet haben ist ja dass sie
sagen es ist eigentlich nur ein erster
Schritt mit den 200 Milliarden wir
werden noch viel mehr tun müssen wir
sind erst am Anfang von
Herausforderungen und gleichzeitig haben
die sich das ja jetzt gerade Lindner ich
sag mal so hin geredet dass es einmalig
ist und versprochen dass es dazu nicht
noch mal kommen würde ist das nicht auch
ein Widerspruch ja ich habe das nicht im
Wortlaut gehört ich weiß nicht genau was
er da gesagt hat
das kann natürlich sein
sicherlich niemand weiß natürlich wie
sich die Preise entwickeln die am
Energiemarkt wenn wir es wüssten setzen
wir nicht hier dann werden wir reich und
deswegen muss man immer ein bisschen
Zeit spielen
noch mehr Krisen auch bekommen es wird
hier jetzt nicht so sein dass dass die
letzte bleibt und man kann davon
ausgehen dass wieder neue
Schattenhaushalte entstehen müssen und
deswegen wäre es eigentlich gut wie mir
auch sagte sich ehrlich zu machen und
dann ist auch klar so benennen wie es
ist und dann wirklich darüber
nachzudenken kann man nicht diesen
Mythos Schuldenbremse einmal ablegen und
auch einfach der Bevölkerung erklären ja
es gibt die schwäbische Hausfrau so
sollte man zu Hause ein bisschen
Haushalten aber ein Staatshaushalt
funktioniert dann völlig anders und wir
haben es mit einem Land zu tun das Reich
ist das anerkannt ist dass eine stabiler
Regierung hat über Jahrzehnte und das
ist ein Land in das gern investiert wird
und dass sich viel mehr leisten kann und
wo man jetzt wirklich auch noch mal ganz
klar vorausgehen kann also wo man auch
noch mal die Möglichkeit hat die
zeitenwände auch mit anderen Inhalten
als nur mit Aufrüstung aufzublasen weil
jemand vielleicht zum Schluss also wir
beschreiben den Vertrauensverlust den
die Regierungsparteien hatten aber Frau
Höning hat auch deutlich gemacht dass
Herr März da auch nicht immer auf einem
Kurs gesegelt ist auf dem man gerne
mitgefahren wäre im Nachhinein ich sehe
auch zum Beispiel in Ostdeutschland zwei
CDU regierte Länder wo
Ministerpräsidenten extrem unter Druck
stehen vielleicht einfach zum Schluss
noch der Gedanke wie kann insgesamt da
wieder Vertrauen aufgebaut werden
große Aufgabe sie spielen sicherlich auf
den Bericht des ostbeauftragten an der
diese Woche spielt Alber generell dass
alle Parteien da gar kein neues Fass
aufmachen aber alle Parteien ja um
Vertrauen kämpfen
ich glaube Konsistenz und sich ehrlich
machen ist schon mal ein gutes Mittel
den der Bevölkerung auch immer wieder
erklären warum wir das was wir machen
gerade machen ich sehe das im Osten die
Zustimmung zu den Sanktionen schwindet
ich kann da nur eine Umfrage von der IHK
Nord Brandenburg oder Ostbrandenburg war
es zitieren wonach über 50 Prozent der
Unternehmen sagen wir sind ganz hart
betroffen von diesen Sanktionen
existenzbedrohend und zwei Drittel sagen
die müssen gelockert werden und das
spiegelt unter anderem auch die Stimmung
in der Bevölkerung wieder insofern ist
der Schutzschirm der jetzt aufgespannt
wird auch ein Schutzschirm für die
Solidarität mit der Ukraine generell
werbe ich auch für einen anderen Blick
auf die Ostdeutschland also nicht immer
nur wenn es brennt sondern auch mal zu
sagen okay was habt ihr erreicht wir
nehmen eure Sorgen ernst und die
Ostdeutschen kennenkrise das hat sich im
kollektiven Bewusstsein sehr tief
eingegraben die wissen was das heißt
wenn Betriebe massenhaft pleite gehen
wenn sie schließen müssen wenn Menschen
entlassen werden und das muss man ernst
nehmen wir haben mit doppelbums
angefangen sie haben jetzt von einer
ehrlichen offenen Kommunikation
gesprochen
ich sehe da noch ein gewisses
Spannungsfeld bedanke mich herzlich für
diese Runde wünsche Ihnen wenn Sie in
der ARD dabei bleiben viel Spaß beim
Bericht aus Brüssel mit Markus Preis der
das Thema fortsetzt oder bei Phoenix und
im Radio Presseclub nachgefragt und im
Netz natürlich lassen Sie es gut gehen
[Musik]
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Radio bei WDR 5 im Netz
bei Presseclub und tagesschau.de und im
Fernsehen bei Phoenix wir beginnen in
Neumarkt in der Oberpfalz ich begrüße
Werner Schenkel guten Tag sie haben das
Wort
Herr Schenkel sind sie am Hörer
das ist offenbar nicht der Fall dann
würde ich sagen springen wir einfach
nach Berlin zu Hans grandj hallo Herr
grandj
ja hallo in die Runde ich glaube das
meine Frage schon angesprochen wurde
während ich telefoniert habe ich stelle
sie trotzdem noch mal das geht um die
Frage können Sie mich verstehen kann sie
gut verstehen wir sind bei ihnen absolut
ich wollte an die Frage an die Runde
stellen die Frage stellen ob das ist
dieses Jahr vierte Paket tatsächlich
auch wieder sozusagen Gießkanne ist also
an alle
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ausgezahlt wird
also diese Deckelung für einen
bestimmten
Gasverbrauch während der eigentlich alle
fast alle Parteien beteuert haben jetzt
wird nur noch
spezifiziert und nicht wie es kann mäßig
nach
beispielsweise nach Einkommen oder so
glaube ich pro Monat schon 4000 Mark
Euro als Grenze angesprochen
Punkt ist in der Tat Frau Höning hatte
das angesprochen deshalb Herr Schmidt
hat sich jetzt auch gemeldet würde ich
sagen Herr Schmidt ihre Perspektive
darauf tatsächlich eine Gießkanne und
wir können das glaube ich auf die
Schnelle so nicht besser lösen was aber
damit nicht gesagt ist dass wir noch was
anderes brauchen nämlich wir brauchen
noch mal ganz konkrete Entlastung für
die Haushalte die tatsächlich besonders
hart getroffen sind von Inflation von
den hohen Energiepreisen und da muss man
auch ganze klar erkennen es braut sich
was zusammen und man kann es im Internet
gut nachvollziehen also wir haben so
gesehen die
ü40 Ü40 50 Leute die radikalisieren sich
über Facebook die
U25 Leute radikalisieren sich über
tiktok man muss nur mal sehen wie
erfolgreich Alice Weidel Videos dort
sind wo sie vom heißen Herbst redet
davon dass die Menschen bald nichts mehr
haben werden das sind Videos die werden
500.000 Mal geliked die haben über 4
Millionen Klicks und da braut sich bei
jungen Leuten ein großer Hass auf den
Staat zusammen und dem kann man nur
entgegnen den man zeigt der Staat macht
auch was hier wir helfen danke ich
mir geht nur durch den Kopf dass wir in
sozialen Netzwerken ja auch viele
scheinriesen haben und alle Klicks nicht
immer einzelne Entscheidungen sind
sondern auch Mechanismen gibt solche
Dinge zu befördern aber vielen Dank Herr
grandiot ich grüße sie noch mal schönen
Sonntag nach Berlin und bin in Wetzlar
hoffentlich bei Ulrike Schönberger Frau
Schönberger guten Tag
ja hallo guten Tag in die Runde
die Mehrwertsteuer für Gast und
Fernwärme soll auf 7% gesenkt werden für
Holz und Pellets ist sie schon bei
7%. wann wird die Mehrwertsteuer für
Heizöl auf 7% gesenkt und da hätte ich
einen Vorschlag und zwar rückwirkend und
zwar ab dem Zeitpunkt wo die Menschen
Heizöl eingelagert haben für den Winter
und das könnte man auch dann über die
Steuererklärung 2022
Regeln in dem dann die Differenz
erstattet wurde okay darf ich eine ganz
zarte Vermutung äußern heizen Sie
eventuell mit Öl
origineller
Vorschlag kommen die Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer hat man ja auch nur
gemacht als Begleitung zur gasumlage und
dann wollte man nicht den politischen
Flop machen nach Abschaffung der
gasumlage den Menschen auch das
wegzunehmen deshalb glaube ich können
sie sich keine Hoffnung machen auch wenn
es natürlich gut ist dass sie
rechtzeitig angefangen haben einzulagern
also wir können Ihnen keine Hoffnung
machen jedenfalls Frau Höning gibt da
eine sehr klare Prognose ab tut mir leid
Frau Schönberger
ja also bei mir geht ein Gedanke durch
den Kopf weiß nicht ob der richtig ist
aber
die Chance mit einer Ölheizung nicht von
Lieferunterbrechungen betroffen zu sein
ist natürlich größer weil man da selber
bevorraten kann während man natürlich
bei Gas immer von vielen anderen
abhängig ist aber das nur als Gedanke
Gruß nach Wetzlar
diesen in Meldorf grüß Gott
bitte sie sind dran ja ich würde mal
dazu raten etwas mehr Demut in die Runde
zu bringen ich führe einen Teil einen
großen Teil der jetzt vorne Inflation
auch auf die Auswirkungen des
Koalitionsvertrags der Ampel zurück also
ein Jahr her das hätte schon die
Beschlüsse dort hätten schon dazu
geführt dass in Inflation von ich
schätze mal zwei bis drei Prozent
mindestens gekommen wären und ich führe
das darauf zurück dass man ja doch da
umgedacht hat mit SPD und Grünen das
letztendlich wir nicht so zündhaft
Kosten der Umwelt und vor allem nicht
auf Kosten der Dritten Welt unser Leben
gestalten können also in dem Augenblick
wo wir etwas mehr sparen etwas mehr
Enthaltsamkeit üben denke ich mal würden
wir auch unser Leben besser in den Griff
bekommen ich weiß sehr wohl für einen
Teil der Bevölkerung ganz schwer ist die
von der Hand in den Mund leben aber es
gibt genügend Leute die wohl situiert
sind so wie ich und die durchaus durch
Verzicht auch einsparen können ich will
ein kleines Beispiel noch anfügen ich
habe letztens einen Film gesehen wo eine
gut durchgestylte junge
Ladenbesitzerin darüber jammerte dass
sie jetzt nicht mehr so viele Klamotten
verkaufen kann und ich höre andererseits
dass Leute shoppen und einkaufen und
gerade Klamotten an solche Sachen die
kaum getragen werden und das ist alten
Fehlentwicklung und solchen
Fehlentwicklung gilt es Einhalt zu
gebieten und das wofür ist die Krise
sozusagen eine gute Chance Herr diesen
vielen herzlichen Dank für diesen
Gedanken ich sehe das gar nicht als
Frage sondern als ein Appell oder ein
Argument insofern danke und
auf Wiederhören Monika halli in
Mönchengladbach ist die nächste Frau
Hallig guten Tag
guten Tag in die Runde ich habe folgende
Frage und zwar ist ja auch immer viel
unter Solidarität unter Europäern die
Rede gewesen jetzt gerade nicht mehr
ganz so aktuell jetzt kommt dann noch
mal gasmangelage als Stichwort auf die
Fülle der garspeicher oder der Füllstand
die garspeicher sind ja eigentlich dafür
da uns mit gut über den Winter zu
bringen aber auch nur zum Teil was ist
wenn jetzt die unter
solidaritätsgründen Gas auch an die
Meistbietenden
außer deutschen
Gaslieferanten das Gas auch noch weiter
in das europäische Ausland geht und
dadurch unsere gasmangelage eigentlich
verschlimmert wird also ihre Sorge ist
dass sag mal mehr bietende in anderen
Ländern das Gas bekommen dass wir als
Vorrat gespeichert haben ja das wird
nicht alles sein aber
dass da ein Teil davon eben mit runter
geht dass wir das mit berücksichtigen
dass wir mit weiter Gas sparen damit wir
überhaupt über den Winter kommen
das ist eine gute Frage allerdings
glaube ich die Prämisse Stände ich
glaube nicht dass uns irgendein Land
überbieten wird weil wir haben die
finanzpower das gedroht nicht aber es
ist tatsächlich eine gute Frage nach der
europäischen Solidarität denn da gibt es
auch ein Mechanismus und es ist richtig
dass das Gas das in den deutschen
speichern liegt nicht deutsches Gas ist
jeder Energiekonzern Europas kann diese
Speicher buchen und dort gab es
einlagern und wann das ausgespeichert
wird durch wen das war das wissen wir
schlicht untergreifend nicht wir wissen
die thi die deutsche Firma die dafür
zuständig war die hat für 13 Milliarden
Euro quasi deutsches Gas beschafft das
liegt da drin darüber kann man ziemlich
sicher verfügen wie viel uniper
eingespart hat die anderen deutschen
Unternehmen das wissen wir nicht also es
könnten wir sollten nicht sagen die
Speicher sind zu 90% voll und das ist
alles unser Gas das ist nicht richtig
bei mir gar nicht bewusst danke
interessante Informationen fragalli
Grüße nach Mönchengladbach wir haben
viele
Anrufe heute Netzwerken ist auch viel
los Hauke Büsing in Gelsenkirchen ist
der nächste ja einen schönen guten Tag
auch in die Runde was mich gerne mal
interessiert wie die Runde das sieht
dass die Politik nicht gerade sagt dass
wir mehr eigentlich einsparen müssten
also diese heilige Kuh vom Eis genommen
wird dass wir wirklich einsparen müssen
und nicht im Urlaub fliegen und uns zu
tun als wenn nichts mehr mich gehabt das
Gefühl als wenn er das bis zum
übernächsten Winter alles nicht
eingehalten wird
Frau Lehmann Wahnsinn also es gibt ja
Appelle Gas einzusparen das tut Robert
Habeck ja auch und es gibt bereits
Einsparungen zum Beispiel bei der
Industrie wobei der da ist der
verbrauchen 20% runtergegangen wobei das
nicht so ist dass das ist nicht halt nur
als positiv zu bewerten also es ist
natürlich auch hat natürlich auch mit
Produktionsrückgang zu tun aber
natürlich könnten wir auch auf anderen
Feldern einsparen Stichwort Tempolimit
wieso leisten wir es uns können mit 180
km/h durch die Welt zu sausen auch Öl
zählt ja zu den fossilen Rohstoffen
besonders da findet eine Preisexplosion
statt sie haben Recht man könnte auch
stärker über Einsparungen reden nur gibt
es das Problem wenn wir jetzt über
Verzicht reden dann ist so etwas wie ich
verzichte auf schnelles Autofahren das
eine problematisch wird es dann wenn man
sagt ja die Leute sollen jetzt auch mal
darauf verzichten ins Hotel zu gehen ins
Restaurant zu gehen all diese Dinge zu
machen das ist ja auch unsere Wirtschaft
das ist ja nicht von uns irgendwie
losgekoppelt sondern das kann auch dann
eine Arbeitslosigkeit produzieren wenn
man diese Art von Konsum verzichtet dass
wir generell den Konsum transformieren
müssen hin zu einem klimafreundlicheren
das ist vollkommen klar aber jetzt mit
Verzicht kommen wir da eine ganz ganz
heikle Lage nämlich wenn noch die
Arbeitslosigkeit oder so etwas droht
dann ist die Regierung auch irgendwann
nicht mehr in der Lage das einfach mit
ein bisschen Geld zu steuern Herr Büsing
danke Sie haben gemerkt eine kleine
Debatte angestoßen was ich eigentlich
immer versuche zu vermeiden aber da war
ich nicht aufmerksam genug Gruß nach
Gelsenkirchen und jetzt bin ich gespannt
auf Friedrich Otto in Gilserberg guten
Tag
guten Tag
wird die öffentliche Hand jemals ihre
Schulden zurückzahlen oder Tod eine
Inflation wie 1923 und 1948 hat Japan
sie zu 250% Verschuldung genutzt und hat
der Juliusturm Deutschland geschadet
vielen Dank Herr Otto wird die
öffentliche Hand jemals ihre Schulden
zurückzahlen oder haben wir Inflation
den 1923 die öffentliche Hand zahlt ja
nie ihre Schulden zurück sondern sie
löst den einen Kredit durch den anderen
ab aber die berechtigte Sorge des Lesers
ist ja kriegen wir so eine
Hyperinflation wie in den 20er Jahren
ich glaube da können wir beruhigende
Signale senden das wird nicht passieren
wir werden jetzt drei rate Jahre weil
die Europäische Zentralbank zum Beispiel
ja endlich verstanden hat was angesagt
ist und auf die
zinspedal drückt es wird viele weitere
Zinserhöhungen geben und damit geht sie
dagegen vor aber um die Rezession kommen
geht herum nur eine ganz kleine
Anmerkung nein keine Anmerkung denn
Hörerinnen und Zuschauer haben Vorrang
User auch Kirsten Nielebock in Hamburg
ist die nächste
Hamburg ich habe mal eine Frage wann
kommt der pressewurms weil gerade wenn
man das Konsumverhalten gezielt lenken
will wie Herr Schmidt das gerade sagte
warum sollen wir abwarten ob alles
schief geht lasst uns doch jetzt
loslegen und dass die Presse täglich
eine Medien nutzt und uns Konsumenten
Tipps gibt damit wir mehr Anspruch haben
und mehr Bescheid wissen und ansonsten
vielen Dank für die interessante Runde
vielen Dank für diesen Impuls der uns
vermutlich alle am Tisch beschäftigt und
ich kommentiere das gar nicht mal so ein
gucke mal also Herr Schmidt hat sich
schon gerührt vielleicht lasse ich da
doch zwei drei ganz kurze Antworten so
naja die Presse soll ja vor allem
aufklären und dann kann man ja auch als
mündiger Bürger selbst überlegen was ist
das sinnvolle und ich glaube Leute die
sparen müssen wissen ohnehin wie zu
sparen ist und da muss glaube ich jetzt
gar nicht mehr so eine große Kampagne da
sein die Botschaft ist ja längst
verstanden und internalisiert Frau
Lehmann ich sehe unsere Aufgabe auch
eher da drin einzuordnen und nicht zu
agitieren aber wenn sie mal im Archiv
der Schatz gucken da gibt es auch Tipps
wie man durch ein zwei Grad weniger
Heizenergie einsparen kann
ehrlich gesagt ich halte von solchen
Verbraucher Tipps aber wenig weil die
Menschen nicht sparen müssen die wissen
wie sie sparen müssen die brauchen nicht
unsere das sehe ich ganz anders wir
wollen nicht agitieren unsere Aufgabe
ist es aufzuklären und Rat zu geben und
bei der Rheinischen Post die
meistgelesenen Artikel der letzten drei
Monaten sind jeden Tag neue wie spare
ich beim Heizen wie spare ich beim
Lüften also
verbraucherjournalismus können wir nicht
genug machen danke für diese Bestärkung
muss ich ebenso Werbung machen die
Verbraucherthemen in der Welt und der
Welt am Sonntag sind sehr stark gefragt
und wir legen eine sehr sehr viel Wert
darauf
ich kann ehrlich gesagt also ich lese
und höre auch viel und kann trotzdem
ihre Frage verstehen weil es mir auch so
schwer fällt wirklich Orientierung zu
finden was nötig und gerade das Richtige
ist weiß nicht wie geht es Ihnen
[Musik]
ein bisschen runterdrehen verstehe ich
aber natürlich wo ist das Verhältnis ab
wann man komplett nicht halt und also
ich auch wenn ich mich informiere und
dankbar für alle Medien und auch für
Ihre Sendung würde ich mich freuen wenn
das einfach so weitergeht dass wir
täglich gezielte Tipps bekommen
vielleicht auch mal aus dem Fernsehen
mehr also mündlich bin ich mitmachen
billig ich will nur dass wir alle nicht
scheitern das wollen wir gemeinsam danke
für Ihren Impuls tschüss nach Hamburg
Herr Wetzel Jochen Adler aus
Braunschweig fragt warum reden wir nicht
mehr darüber wer in dieser Krise
verdient
oder tun wir ja wir haben ja
festgestellt dass es übergewinne gibt
oder zufallsgewinne gibt wie das der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister nennt und die
werden abgeschöpft auf europäischer
Ebene den wird viel Geld weggenommen
also den wird 90 Prozent dieser
übergewinne
weggesteuert kann man fast sagen also da
wird schon gesehen dass dieser dieser
Preismechanismus Ungerechtigkeiten
produziert diese Meret order Kurve ist
es am Strommarkt heißt und da wird jetzt
angegriffen tatsächlich in dem die der
maximale Gewinn auf 180 Euro die
Megawattstunde begrenzt vielen Fragen
heute steckt auch das Bedürfnis das
Gerechtigkeit in einer schwierigen
Situation eine Rolle spielt ich denke
diese Frage gehört auch dazu danke für
ihre vielen Impulse Kommentare Fragen
Anrufe danke hier am Tisch Ihnen noch
einen schönen Sonntag Gruß aus Köln
[Musik]